all right can we get please a big
collider hero's welcome from me and from
COI to our guest today Andrew Howard
from what Sherman hello how's it going
going great thank you so much for being
here oh it's my absolute pleasure bah
humbug
respect it my daughter loves this she's
like good be it also suits your
character like looking behind you and
looking right there like this all kind
of blends together money behind them
yeah it's good I kept the red theme
going
so of course you play Red Scare on
Watchmen which has become one of our
favorite shows of all time yeah I mean
absolutely there that I have people
crawling out of the woodwork celebrating
the fact that this is a monumental show
and I think something that that um you
know it underground Li crossed over
culturally mmm do you know what I mean
yeah and really made an impact because
it's not just comic book it's it's
telling a really really wonderful tale
about American history and how its put
us in the place right now and did it in
a weird and wonderful bonkers beautiful
way and I'm so so proud to be part of it
I really am it and I'm I think Lindelof
is a genius and the people that he hired
to work on the show a brilliant so it's
it's a in a magnificent moment in my in
my life yeah and we'll see what happens
down the road
no it's shows dichotomies it's a show of
like extreme polarity because you're
you're your super suit effectively is
the most grounded thing I've ever so I
have seen guys wearing this and then
you're also in scenes where it's raining
squids now for you as a performer what's
it like being on a set that is so like
the juxtaposition that's crazy well that
was perfect and that was a way that I
helped build a character or how we built
the character is that the show is is on
one level very rudimentary and very
low-tech
but at the same time it's way beyond
what we what we're having and being
served by now there's no internet so
therefore the internet is that the
internet is in its infancy so in terms
of Big Brother and those giant World
Wide Web algorithms that are dominating
our lives right now that's not there so
there's still some some kind of
innocence to people because I think
we've all been corrupted now but there
is still a Big Brother and the police
now in masks in Tulsa and and the
question comes up - the police need to
be policed etc etc but in terms of of
being in a high tech low tech world I
think that juxtaposition partly cuts
through what the show is about which is
the split in society right now or one of
the themes of the show and so yeah it
was idle I was so delighted to be
wearing such a shitty it's absolutely
wonderful I'm I'm I'm I mean number one
just just as a as a as an actor
artistically to get into a trailer and
always look at the call terms in the
mornig oh yeah they put me in for like
eight minutes to get ready which is
which is brilliant because we're
shooting in Atlanta and now and so I'm
like oh great I can set the you know
Regina's in at five Clark Kent walking
into the opposite of every other
superhero property here's my mask
absolutely absolutely and and and then I
I was able to have that mask just in my
hand
everyone's fixed and trust and you know
it takes an hour of assistance to get it
all ready before one take and they go
you ready and I go yep there the night
before getting blue yeah
2 a.m. cold kind of cold times yeah but
um I mean we had to finagle it a bit I
was you know for the dialogue and for me
eating and stuff we had to make sure
that it it felt like an old crusty piece
of
an old crusty friend and and to make
sure that you could you know I could
speak because the original one they gave
me I was like that wide mouth frog jokes
it's one of my daughter's favorite now
thematically what do you see is the
difference between a masked vigilante
and a masked cop because that's one of
the big questions of the show
and you got to play someone that had to
deal with that walking that line I I
think there's a there's a real
similarity to it I think that obviously
the police at the moment a very
polarizing identity in the in the
country at the moment and and we really
need to address the way the cops have
helped or been a part of dividing this
country through their actions but
conversely on the other side of the
fence
we need cops more than ever we need
policing otherwise we're [ __ ]
[Laughter]
otherwise we're screwed we're screwed
ray know that if we don't have please
society is screwed but I don't think
police should be wearing masks in any
way shape or form and the police
shouldn't have to be protecting their
family and being threatened by their
families and that's what it all boils
down to and that's the crux of this guy
and Regina's character is to protect
their identity because they want to try
and protect their families so it's a
fascinating dichotomy yeah so it
absolutely is one of the things that
stands out in the series is that every
corner you look in you just want to zoom
in and get the whole story but we had a
limited amount of time we got to spend
with them and Red Scare was one of my
favorite parts of that I want I want to
know more I want to know do you have a
hole do you know a lot about Red Scare
that we don't know yet no hmm oh do I
hey no no I don't know absolutely there
was there was a huge process because
there was so much secrecy because Damon
and his team had to safeguard so much of
what was about to be exposed I mean I
don't think Yaya knew he was Manhattan
until you know night before he's about
to be painted [ __ ] blue it's
incredible no that's not no nobody but
it was during the season he'd been hired
as his husband and and yet truly he
wasn't told until I mean there must have
been messages from from agents saying he
needs to accept this role I would assume
I mean I've had the odd wink-wink in the
past and on this but there must have
been a big you've got two days learn a
militant what's it like to know
everything search but so and so from my
point of view I was I was very in the
dark Damon I was one of the first cast
apart from Regina who the row was
written for her there was a I wouldn't
have a CW show in Utah with a great
bunch of people with no budget and
having a lot of fun and then I got a
call saying can you put yourself down on
tape for Watchmen and I thought oh my
goodness watchman and then Damon
Lindelof Wow so I did a bit of a google
and saw how Damon had been you know
obsessed with it since his father gave
him the that the novel on on his laughs
you know way back when and and so I was
immediately intrigued and then I got
this monologue which was an
extraordinary monologue of a basically
him I don't know if I can say this but
whatever basically him in a confessional
box talking about this event that
happened in his life
hmm so I read it and I and it's a
beautiful piece of dialogue that de
Monroe as the audition piece for the
character but on paper the character
said a behemoth a giant giant guy who
you can imagine in that environment in
that world you could see that dynamic
happening with Angela and Looking Glass
and then this giant you know red glow
but they saw my tape I made this little
tape and I never resonated with them and
then as from that moment on I was their
guy Damon and and Nicky Cassell who's
excited for two friends I directed the
pilot so I'm so I you know I made this
little tape and it took like 20 minutes
but I guess I had the bones of what is
behind the mask and know what you see is
the exterior and you play
larger-than-life character like I love
your turn and limitless and then you do
Alex on stage like these characters are
all like huge physically by their
presents not by their actual physicality
is that something that you're drawn to
as an actor do you want to play
characters that have just so much to
them as soon as you meet them like this
is this guy no I love getting physical I
love getting you know I love getting the
Brawn out but I think essentially what's
good about me as an actor is is that I'm
good at playing the villain but there's
gotta be some sensitive side behind it
and some some reality and I think I'm
good at finding that that little
position and also the other thing you
know with limitless and one of the
reasons why I got that job is because
you got a decoupling villains with the
twinkle in your eyes you can't you see
all these guys trying to be trying to be
mean and and they look like idiots you
gotta do it you gotta do with a smile on
your face yeah if your mustache twirling
there has to be more there exactly
exactly yeah
I'm the ultimate
you deliver such a funny human
performance for this character who could
have been like a scary dude only yeah
but has so many sides to him yeah
absolutely and I think that's what's
what's great about him and and you know
we kind of built on the day the first
scene in the in the show where you see
us in the precinct I was in the
scripture said I was eating a doughnut
and I went I mean I'm gonna freakin we
called balaclavas where he come from his
ski mask I'm in a [ __ ] ski mask and
I'm eating the donor I'm like that's
interesting so I went right let's make
that let's make that an essential part
of who he is and let's metabolize this
[ __ ] and make sure that whenever
we see him if we can he's eating so just
those little beats suddenly he impose
upon you differ you know defining and
bringing life to the character so then
you know for instance I'm then next time
we're in the precinct and I go to the
the the medic on set who says one
wonderful wonderful like Haiti and
cheesy in chios with a plastic fork and
I'm like she's but she's a she's a nurse
and she's got enough people get sick or
something she's got her hands are gonna
be clean so I was like I'm stealing that
and so that becomes the next moment
where I've got a pack of what a pack of
cheese it and I've got my cheese's and
I've got my plastic fork so you just
kind of as an actor you know yeah like
um you know like a volte just scram you
know scrambling around for goods and so
that's how they could the character
build obviously the the Wardrobe was in
place of the add the offset and I I have
so many references for the film but one
of one of my big personal references for
the movie and and for my character is um
old boy mm-hmm
which is one of my favorite films and
and I kept going back to moments of that
and I guess I had my own little
fantasies that I'd have that big slow-mo
which you know down the road I'll do it
someday but um but it informed me and
then I went and met Nicky herself
extraordinary direction yeah yeah
brilliant woman brilliant woman like you
you can't say enough about it Damon was
so smart to get on board and and what
she brought to it the levity in the band
and the wit and it's I mean it's people
can't get over how filmic it is but
gumpa going back to that I walked into
her office when she was her production
office in Atlanta the first day I met
her after having conversations on the
phone and emails and I walked into a her
office and her mood board was giant of
you know there was everything I mean the
show is everything there was everything
was there
you know from Kubrick everything was
there and I zoomed in on this photo of
Oldboy I was like oh we are the same
page we're on the same page now you're
doing a show that has basically nine
movies worth of styles and choices and
direction and we're each of the scripts
did you do they have a different tone
when you're reading them the first time
did they all feel different cuz like
episode six is so different than nine
and eight so different than two and no I
every time you thought you were reading
a new a new epic movie that was gonna be
out in 2022 I mean really they are there
I know Lindelof says the whole season
stands alone but I think every episode
stands alone you don't need to know what
happened before to just be engaged and
and infused by what you're seeing yeah I
mean I have never read a script where
and it was so secretive getting you know
you couldn't get it [ __ ] hard copy of
your life and and I and I finally did
get a couple of hard copies it was like
my seven years old yeah yeah and but
ever but every time I read them they
were they were so dense so deep I'm a
I'm a novice of Watchmen but obviously I
did my homework I read I read the bread
the graphic novels it was still
astonishing to try and figure out how
are they gonna shoot this how is this
this is a TV show how are they gonna
bring this off and I think I mean it was
us not a struggle but it was a huge feat
a huge effort to bring it to fruition I
know that you know we shut down for for
for a couple of months not because
anything was wrong but just because
everyone had to take stop and and and
and make sure that everyone was up to
speed because everyone realized that
they were building such a huge world
that it was you know it was hard too
hard to bring off but I think they did
it stupendously I mean it's you know my
girl my girlfriend the smoke we watched
that because I know we will come and we
watch the finale this and and you know
she's a journalist she's a she's a she
has an opinion and she is just how did
you how did they how did they do this
how did they bring this so sick
cyclically perfectly back together and
make it a huge round people have people
have really knocked out by a so I'm you
know I we do a comic book show and I
think it's the best adaptation of
something that I didn't think was able
to be adapted it is perfect and I really
appreciate with with his team crystal
Henry who's an extra cargo cop and and
now an executive producer and writer on
the show I mean he couldn't have brought
together such a magnificent team oh my
gosh so the the assembled superheroes
who made the show I think I'm very
excited for us all to get familiar with
but you are also kind of part of the HBO
family
right I mean you have more stuff coming
up yeah I'm uh I'm sitting very
awkwardly today because yesterday I was
um I was beating two with an inch in my
life all night I mean really shouldn't
say too much
no I'm June Perry Mason which is another
just giant beautiful golden egg that I'm
you know so proud to be part of you know
I'm super lucky to be by to be part of
it and I get I get to put in the 1930s
three-piece four-piece what an outfit
and I'm a I'm an LA it's suddenly I'm
transformed to an LAPD cop in 1929 yarn
into 9:30 post depression Perry Mason is
you know it was a procedural show in the
60s on TV with Raymond Burr but HBO of
taken it back and Felix and Jones who
write the show and run the show they've
gone back and Downey jr. collective
Robert and his wife overseeing the whole
show they think it was gonna be the only
jr. I was gonna play Perry originally
but then some farmyard animals got in
the way I think so I'm sort of so the
role got given to Matthew Reese from the
Americans who's one of my oldest friends
no yeah we we we did a play on stage
together at the National Theatre in
London 26 years ago Wow I loved reading
about your stage experience and partly
because / cocooned is just one of my
favorite place and I wish I could travel
back in time and see that again Wow but
I love the way bouncing around to that
different kind of work creates such
strong performers obviously oh well
thank you yeah no it was a
it was my first play in London after
touring doing like doing stock theatre
for five six years when I was out of
college and then and then I booked this
gig in London and the first day I walked
in and man Matthew is this young 24 year
old skinny kid who just got out of the
Royal Academy and and then 26 years
later we're in downtown Los Angeles
shooting the show I think roads on let's
go and and these extraordinary actors
Shea Whigham and it's just a myriad of
brilliant brilliant performance I mean
the ensemble is extraordinary and I'm
I'm in such a laugh and I'm doing my
doing it's fun well congratulations from
one giant ensemble to another and Stan
the HBO family and the opposite wardrobe
it sounds like takes me a [ __ ] hour
well thank you so much for being with us
please come back any time I will I'll
come back next year and I can tell you
more about Perry meds I want to hear
about the scene we know about the
effects of today perfect you so much
again then one trick is my dad you and
you and your your little gift bag
outside you've got these walk words this
is my daughter's favorite cake that's
how we get back over to your family
right